welcome back to my round two game from
the fuay blitz tournament this one I'm
playing Grandmaster arcadi nuch who is
currently ranked number 80 in the world
so I knew I would have my work come out
for me in this game and coming into this
game I really just wanted to enjoy
myself have fun play some enterprising
chests not every day you get to play an
elite Grandmaster like this so
definitely wanted to seize
opportunity and we shake hands the game
begins I opted for Pawn E4 on move one
he played as a sicilian and I played
Knight to C3 which is one of my favorite
pet lines against the Sicilian uh this
can very often go into a Grand Prix
attack after Knight C6 Bishop to B5 I
did give a lecture about this line a few
years ago for the St Louis chess club
and already he begins to hesitate which
in the moment I thought was a good sign
that he he maybe caught off guard in
opening but in hindsight I think he was
just trying to choose what line to play
uh the main line is Knight to D4 but he
plays Knight to F6 which is a secondary
move I take on
C6 and then he does have a choice which
Pawn to take back with he takes away
from the center I play Pawn to D3 and
one reason that black takes away from
the center is to accelerate development
of the lights were Bishop also open up
the queen but going forward from here I
was already feeling like very
comfortable I've played this position a
lot in uh online games and I'm going for
a Grand Pre attack structure with F4
preparing Knight F3 and castling and
very often I'll play this sort of
structure against amateur players and
just have a very good win percentage but
this time I'm playing this against a
very strong grandm so I was curious in
the moment what he's going to come up
with and he plays a kind of surp
surprising move Pawn to C4 sacrificing a
pawn in an effort to weaken my structure
and now I have to decide do I take the
pawn on C4 double my pawns and allow a
queen trade or do I maybe just continue
with
development so I took a moment here to
consider my options but I went ahead and
snagged the material and we trade Queens
on D1 I take with the King to ensure my
knight still defends Pawn on e4 and then
he plays Pawn E5 so this is yet another
Pawn sacrifice where uh still less than
10 moves into the Keem and he's already
sacrificing two pawns with black from
the Sicilian Defense not something you
see every day from a top grandmas but E5
I think is a very thematic move he's
trying to accelerate development of his
dark for Bishop and if I take the pawn
then he'll have the move Knight G4 to
attack F2 and also a threaten to
recapture on
E5 so I was trying to figure out how to
deal with this I do decide to take on
E5 and uh yeah after Knight to G4 I play
a delayed Bon Cloud King to E2 and I'm
not so worried at this point with my
king being in the center especially
because Queens are off the board thought
my king is just a useful piece
preventing Knight F2 trying to get my
Rooks connected as quickly as possible
and he took a moment here before
recapturing on E5 uh maybe debating
whether to play Bishop B4 or Bishop E6
first but eventually he does Recapture
on E5 I quickly play Pawn to B3
reinforcing my C4 Pawn also preparing to
develop my darks for Bishop and he plays
Bishop to B4 attacking my
knight and now now I uh pretty quickly
Play Bishop to B2 simply defending the
knights also getting the bishop to a
nice Square on the long diagonal where
the Knight on E5 or the pawn on G7 could
be eventual targets so I was feeling
very good here I'm up over a minute on
the clock I'm up a pawn and I have a
position even though my pawns are
doubled I have an isolated pawn and E4
um everything is defended and I have
easy development with F3 and the rook's
coming in very
soon so he decides to Castle I quickly
play Knight to F3 offering the trade of
the knights and I was really just trying
to simplify if black takes on F3 I'd be
very happy to recapture with a pawn to
uh have my E4 Pawn supported also to
open the G5 thought maybe later the G7
Pawn could come under Fire and really
the the ball is in Black's Court what to
do here cuz if he doesn't want to
capture on F3 then he either has to
allow the trade or Retreat which he does
with Knight to G6 and this is not a move
that I was initially expecting but when
he played this move I realized this is
actually pretty strong idea because he
avoids the trade and he's preparing
ideas of Knight F4 to harass my king
also attack the undefended pawn on G2 so
I definitely had to be careful here with
Black's threats also I had to just be
cognizant of the fact that e file could
definitely be used by one of Black's
Rooks in the future there's ideas of
Bishop G4 and
F5 and from my perspective I really just
wanted to get my Rooks into play as
quickly as possible I play Rook a D1
getting to the only open file in the
position he plays Rook T E8 aligning
with my king I slide over to F2 getting
off the file of the black rook and now
I'm just preparing Rook to E1 and if I
can get this one last move in then
everything will be solid I'll be up Aon
and I'm still keeping the time Advantage
as well so I think this position is very
critical like black has to do something
right away to ensure that I can't just
keep everything defended and be up a
pawn going into the late stages of the
middle
game and we can see by the body language
here that uh yeah he seemed a little bit
dejected but he plays this move Pawn F5
while leaning back so I'm not sure if he
was dejected or maybe just content with
uh with his commentation in the position
and when he played Pawn F5 he did
briefly look at me I was trying to just
stay focused on the position but here
I'm in a bit of a predicament because I
can't easily play E5 of course he would
just take the pawn and the move I wanted
to play Rook H E1 would just lose back
the pawn because he can take and then
take and then take and uh and black is
keeping the initiative in that line as
well so I took uh a decent amount of
time here trying to figure out how to
deal with this annoying Pawn tension but
after somewhat of a long think I do take
on F5 he recaptures with a bishop and I
play Knight to D4 which is a nice
multi-purpose move not only defending
the C2 Pawn but also attacking the
undefended bishop and undefended Pawn on
C6
so I was still feeling like things are
under control here of course we can see
by the evalar that uh engine already
likes black but it's yeah very difficult
position to correctly evaluate he plays
this move Rook f8 so getting back to the
file of my king and now of course
there's all these nasty discoveries he's
running to take the pawn with check so I
had to be super super careful here
trying to weigh my options do I move my
king off the file do I take the bishop
on
F5 and there is a point earlier in the
game I was up 2 minutes on the clock but
now I'm falling lower on time than my
opponent and still in like a really
tricky situation where can I hide my
king I really wanted to hide it on G1
but then there's ideas of Bishop to C5 I
thought King G3 would be too risky and I
felt like a frozen Rosen in this
situation paralyzed on what move to make
but I do decide to take on a five he
recaptures now I still have to find a
square for my king it seemed like every
option wasn't so appetizing but I play
King to E3 now my king is completely
naked in the center and he starts with
this move Knight H4 which uh basically
throws a punch attacks my Pawn on G2
threatning to play Knight takes G2 with
check and even though I'm still up a
pawn just seems like there's a lot of
issues now with my king side being
attacked my king just clear Target in
the center and I was trying to decide
like do I try and hold on to the pawn do
I try and run with my king I start with
the move A3 I was trying to provoke a
trade on C3 but of course he doesn't
have to trade and he retreats to E7 with
the bishop and I respond with the move
Knight E4 which I think is a nice
centralizing move keeping an eye on the
G5 Square I am allowing him to take on
G2 but then I wouldn't mind opening the
G file for my Rook So he responds with
Rook to E8 using the x-ray vision on
eile I play King to D2 trying to run to
safety he plays Rook F4 attacking my
Knights on e4 I'm falling below 10
seconds trying to figure out how to save
my knight I play Rook D E1
he takes on G2 I play Rook E2 saving the
Rook attacking the
Knight and he hesitates here before
playing Knight to H4 and I play Rook G1
which I instantly regretted because this
allows black pretty simple tactic he's
making sure the tactics work he forks I
play King to E3 and even though I'm
counterattacking The Rook on F4 my Rook
was also attacked so now I'm down a rook
trying to salvage the position then he
simplifies Rook E4 King E4 Bishop F6
check and yeah it's not looking good for
white in this
case I'm basically surviving on the
increment but not really surviving in
the position everything simplifies and
after the dust settles he is up a bishop
and now you can see from his his
Expressions that he's essentially
waiting for me to resign and looking off
to the side I keep playing I was still
fantasizing about maybe creating one
last stem
trick but uh yeah we we see The
Grandmaster technique in this position I
gave him a free pawn and A5
unfortunately I don't even have Rook A1
because of Bishop controls
A1 I centralize my
king then he plays Pawn
A4 trying to just destroy my structure
which he does wins back the pawn on
C4 and yeah I had enough I threw in the
towel and the game ends decisively
losing after 37 Moves In what was a
really really interesting hardfought
game uh it was a fun battle and I really
wasn't disappointed after this game I
think there's a lot of lessons to take
away and before I wrap up the video I do
want to address one of the most critical
moments of the game and it was in this
moment right before I blundered with
this move Rook G1 I think I had seconds
on the clock before I played this move
of course completely missing KN of3 I
was really just fixated on targeting the
G7 Pawn but it turns out in this
position if I play the best move then
white is objectively for Choice the best
move would have been to play Knight D6
not the easiest move to spot but it's
really nice idea to unleash my Rook
pinning the bishop also attacking
Black's Rook on E8 and this would
essentially Force black to play Rook d8
and I would take on E7 and after takes I
would find safety for my king on C1 and
meanwhile just having a very active Rook
attacking A7 and G7 the game could go on
from here black has Rook F7 uh but white
is probably just for Choice with having
really nice bishop and having potential
to still use the G file as well so
perhaps a small missed opportunity but
uh again it can be hard to find such
precise moves in uh in Blitz game
especially when time is very low so uh
yeah this put me at one out of two going
into round three as always I hope you
enjoy the content if you have questions
leave them below if you like the content
subscribe and uh stay tuned for round
three I'll see see you guys soon by